[ÂM NHẠC]
>> Brian Holt: Bây giờ tôi muốn đi đến bài tập ở đây trong đệ quy.
Vì vậy, chúng ta sẽ phân tích giai thừa.
Có hai vấn đề punk mà bất cứ khi nào bạn nói về đệ quy
mọi người luôn nói về, fibonaccis và thừa kế.
Và đoán xem? Bạn phải làm cả hai.
Được rồi, đối với những người bạn không quen thuộc với các giai thừa,
Tôi chắc rằng bạn đã thấy điều này trước năm điểm giải thích đúng.
Và điều đó có nghĩa là 5x4, geez,
x3x2x1 hoặc bạn có thể bỏ đi 1
bởi vì bạn biết đấy, không phải là siêu hữu ích.
Vì vậy, tôi muốn bạn viết một hàm đệ quy làm giai thừa cho bạn.
Vì vậy, giai thừa của một là một giai thừa của hai là hai giai thừa của ba là sáu.
>> Diễn giả 2: Chúng tôi có một số câu hỏi từ ví dụ trước.
>> Brian Holt: Được rồi.
>> Người nói 2: Winny đang hỏi vòng lặp for là gì
tương đương với vòng lặp của hàm Fibonacci?
>> Brian Holt: Tôi không biết rõ điều đó.
Bạn chắc chắn có thể Google nó và có thể trong khi bạn đang thực hiện bài tập của mình,
Tôi có thể xem qua nó.
>> Brian Holt: Vâng, tôi không thể viết nó ra khỏi đầu mình hoặc tôi sẽ không,
nó sẽ mất một lúc.
>> Người nói 2: Và sau đó Benjamin H có một câu hỏi nếu đó là O n log n,
chúng ta vẫn sẽ bỏ bổ ngữ n và chỉ nói O log n?
>> Brian Holt: Đó là một câu hỏi hay.
Câu trả lời là không vì nó không thực sự là hệ số.
Con số đó tăng lên cùng với log n và
thì nó thực sự trở thành con số lớn hơn.
Vì vậy, phần n thực sự quan trọng đối với điều đó và
chìa khóa cần ghi nhớ là nó vẫn còn n, phải không?
Vì vậy, như bạn biết nó tăng từ 5.000 đến 10.000, n sẽ tăng cùng với nó.
Trong khi nếu chỉ là ba, ba vẫn là ba,
bất kể bạn thêm bao nhiêu phần tử, ba phần tử đó vẫn không đổi.
Vì vậy, đó là lý do tại sao chúng tôi giữ nguyên n và nhật ký n,
bởi vì cả hai đều phát triển với tất cả các yếu tố đầu vào mà chúng tôi đưa vào.
Đó là những gì chúng tôi đang tìm kiếm.
Đó là nét chung mà chúng tôi muốn biết.
Đó là một câu hỏi tuyệt vời.
>> Brian Holt: Những câu hỏi hay, hay.
Vì vậy, ở đây, chúng tôi sẽ tạo ra hàm giai thừa này,
chúng tôi đã nói về điều đó một chút.
Và sau đó ở phía dưới đây, chúng tôi có các bài kiểm tra đơn vị cho bạn.
Vì vậy, nếu bạn nhìn xuống đây, đây là một bài kiểm tra đơn vị Jasmine.
Đối với những bạn không quen thuộc với Jasmine,
đó là một khung kiểm tra đơn vị trong JavaScript.
Và nó hy vọng cung cấp cho bạn những lỗi hữu ích.
Đặc biệt là vì chúng tôi đang thực hiện đệ quy,
bút mã sẽ tự động chạy mã của bạn khi bạn đang nhập.
Vì vậy, nếu bạn có thể tưởng tượng nếu bạn đang thực hiện xâm nhập và nó đang chạy mã cho
bạn, bạn sẽ nhận được tràn ngăn xếp.
Vì vậy, hãy tiếp tục và thay đổi điều này thành xdescribe.
Chỉ cần đặt một dấu x trước nó, hoặc bạn cũng có thể đặt dấu x ở đây trước xit.
Đúng? Một trong những điều đó hoạt động tốt.
Điều đó sẽ ngăn các bài kiểm tra đơn vị đó chạy cho đến khi bạn sẵn sàng chạy nó và
sau đó bạn chỉ cần đi xóa nó.
Và tại thời điểm đó, tôi sẽ bắt đầu chạy lại.